[Music]
hey folks welcome to our unity 2020
campfire i am very pleased to introduce
the two guests for this evening ryan
bennett is on
i believe the left part of your screen
and elizabeth sweet is on the right side
of your screen
they are friends of mine who are
volunteers in the unity 2020
organization you'll see that they are
um they are an indication of the amazing
collection of awesome that has arrived
on our doorstep
as a result of people recognizing how
much danger we're in
and how much the republic needs our help
so welcome elizabeth and ryan
thank you thank you great to be here all
right
um so i should correct something i
introduced
a few minutes ago i suggested people go
and log into democracy ai so that they
could interact with us that's still
something that they should um do but in
suggesting that
i made a joke about still fumbling with
tinder in order to get the campfire
going and i got a
flood of correspondence from people
under 35 who alerted me that tinder is
not
only a physical mechanism for starting
fires it is also now a software platform
that allows people to have sex with each
other without having to talk
so i didn't realize that but
anyway my bad uh we were in fact talking
about
uh real tinder of a metaphorical kind
for our campfire so
let me explain a little bit about what
campfire is and why we're using that
metaphor
campfire is a place that for
likely millions of years humans have
gathered
at the point when the light was failing
and
they were therefore no longer going to
be ecologically productive and at those
moments
people would either have talked and
joked and sung and danced
and in times that were not so good they
would have talked about what was
supposed to happen next so we in the
unity movement have appropriated
the metaphor of campfire to stimulate
these kinds of conversations and as
you'll see there's lots of outgrowths
from
using this metaphor among them a
campfire is something that you can
take a an ember from and start your own
discussions which is something we very
much
hope that you will do all right so let's
get to the
business of the evening we have
uh announced six candidates who rose to
the top of our nomination
um program and through democracy
ai you all are going to be telling us
something
about how you feel about those six and
the tickets that they might be
um arranged into uh
through our voting process sorry i'm
struggling a little bit with my
glasses and this font size
okay um so you've logged into democracy
ai
and we are
from the announcement of having six
candidates that can be arranged into
nine tickets
we are going to have a unity 2020
vote that voting process is going to
begin
on tuesday the mechanism for gaining
access to that vote involves being
registered with unity 2020
that means you need to sign up and give
us your email
address join our email list that is the
mechanism so for those of you who have
not yet
signed up with us it is important that
you do that
tonight all right is there anything i've
missed
on that front uh elizabeth and ryan
i think you've covered it all right cool
so you'll receive oh i'll just add one
thing
um you'll receive further instructions
on monday evening for those who have
registered
and the voting begins on tuesday like
brett said
all right great um now we
need to sorry i'm still struggling with
this small
font um
so i think we wanted to talk a little
bit we get a lot of questions in the
unity 2020
movement about um various questions like
what is our ballot access plan obviously
it's too late to collect signatures
we've said that we do have a ballot
access plan etc
we also receive feedback about the fact
that several
people andrew yang has expressed
doubt about the unity um ticket and yet
uh he is on our list of um
nominees dan crenshaw has said he's not
planning to run
for higher office so there's a question
in the air which is what is it that we
are thinking in light of the fact
that some of the people that we have
nominated are apparently not
um yet on board and
we wanted to have a little discussion
about this so you could understand how
we're thinking about it
i think the first thing to say is i
would expect
people who were in a good position
to lead the nation to have this reaction
until
we deliver a groundswell and so
this is uh very much a matter of the
complexity
of the political situation that we find
ourselves in
that is to say andrew yang is
uh simultaneously somebody who appeals
to a great many of us who see the danger
that the republic is in
he represents somebody who has expressed
a new approach that has captured the
imagination
of many and he is also somebody who is
still
functioning within the democratic
establishment so
uh he is in a position where we do not
want him burning bridges
and he does not want to burn bridges and
so we essentially expect
um for him to decline until
we make it clear that there is some path
for him to actually
achieve a leadership position um
you guys want to this goes yeah
so this this goes far beyond andrew yang
this is
every every candidate that has been
nominated for our shortlist they
are all patriots and they are all
willing we would imagine
willing to step up once the american
people
call for them to lead the country and so
we need to create this groundswell
now and we need everyone's support and
we need everyone to show that these are
the leaders that we deserve and that we
need in this country to really lead us
into a future that we can be proud of
and that we are not fearful of because
right now our country is
going in a direction that none of us
want to go in
yeah i would just add to that that you
know
if anyone who wound up on our short list
were to say
yes today to me personally that would be
disqualifying because they wouldn't have
they wouldn't be demonstrating the the
presence of mind
to make hard decisions and take the
proper amount of
calculated risk right it's on us it's on
the people who've already been
volunteering for months
it's on the people listening to this
call to become
inspired and look at the the
you know the trash on either side of the
normal offering reject it and
build the the public call to action
that doesn't ask andrew yang that
doesn't ask dan crenshaw
that doesn't ask any of the other six of
the other four people on our list
but demands it of them as their
patriotic duty
great and so um this
also suggests that um
really the answer to many of these
questions is
one of whether or not we can get enough
people to admit
that they understand that we have to do
something unusual like a unity
2020 proposal in order to give the
legitimacy
that will allow people who who know
that some kind of new leadership is
necessary to join us
publicly so please appreciate the
position
that we are in and also appreciate the
position that
um those who are functioning at a high
level in our political
structure find themselves in it's a very
difficult one and were you in their
shoes
you might very likely recognize the need
for something
new and different and also recognize the
hazard of
being too direct about that in public
all right let's see um
[Music]
next thing on our list
i think we can fire off with the first
question good from democracy ai let's do
it yeah
so why don't we go ahead noah i know
you're not
on camera right now but would you mind
firing off the next question please so
our viewers and our
uh audience participants can can
answer the first question which brett do
you want to kick us off
sorry um is noah not able to do it okay
well no sorry he's kicking off on
democracy ai okay um so i think the
first
the first question uh is
which of the nine possibilities in terms
of tickets that the unity20
uh that the six nominees would generate
which of those tickets uh do you prefer
and why
so all of you were asked in the
onboarding to select a ticket that you
chose
so um we're asking you why did you
choose that ticket and we would like to
see your answers and understand where
where you're at right now
and for those uh watching that uh maybe
didn't get in
until before uh the maximum was reached
on democracy ai
and while that question is being asked
on democracy ai can we
uh maybe enumerate those tickets and
talk a little bit
about the process of assembling a list
of nine
out of a list of six great are you
asking me
sure okay so essentially
what we discovered in our primary
process was that the
unity 2020 community nominated six
people um at a disproportionate level
and it just so happened that three of
those people
were identified as left of center and
three of those people were identified
as right of center so the left of
centers
were tulsi gabbard andrew yang
and jesse ventura
and the right of centers were admiral
mcraven
jocko willink and dan crenshaw
and so we could go through the math here
but it's probably
pretty clear you can take any one of
those left of centers and you can
pair them with uh any one of three on
the right and then you can go to the
second left of center and pair them with
any
one of the three on the right etc and
you come up with nine
possible combinations
now i should remind people why it is
uh that you know there were various
reasons to have a left of center and a
right of center paired but
the most prominent of those reasons and
the most important is that
one of the things that divides americans
is
a fear of the
other side and that the values that one
holds
might be frozen out or is sometimes
frozen out of government when
the pendulum shifts to the other side
and so
in order to break the increasing
polarization
our plan ensures that your values as
long as they're somewhere
near the mainstream are always in the
room that is to say whenever there is a
discussion of what policy direction
to take your values will be represented
somebody in the room understands them
keenly by virtue of the fact that they
are home
values to them and because our team
would be drafted under the agreement
that they would govern together by
consensus
it's not to say that you'll be thrilled
with every policy but it is to say
you can be comfortable that every policy
takes into account that
which you uh hold at the highest level
all right you guys have stuff to add on
this front
i think there's an add-on here oh
elizabeth
no no go for it well there's an add-on
here that there
there's two concerns and one of them you
just laid out which
is you know i i'm say i'm left with
center which i am
you know i want to know that there's a
left of center person in the room
but the reason i'm an early adopter to
unity 2020
is not so much because i want
a leftist center voice in the oval
office or in any position of power
because i'm looking around me and i'm
seeing
my my neighbors my fellow citizens
you know inches away from tearing out
each other's
each other's throat and i'm seeing that
as a consequence
of their insecurity so when
nove when the morning of november 4th
arrives in 2020
and we have an answer that's part of the
duopoly
the the people that are most
the people that are driven most insane
by not having a voice in the oval office
are going to be very distraught and that
distress is going to manifest it and
that's
that's part of the danger that i think
we're trying to prevent with this
movement it's not just the danger
of a trump it's not just the danger of a
biden it's the danger
of large populations of our fellow
citizens
reacting to their fear of not being
represented
by causing massive amounts of civil
unrest
so yes i want to feel represented as
part of the unity ticket
but i also want my
opponent my political opponents to feel
represented by a unity ticket
so that the temperature of the nation
lowers because the temperature has been
rising
steadily and at a increasing rate of
change for several months now
i think that's very very well said
elizabeth did you want to jump in
i have some results actually from um
from democracy ai that i'd like to share
about about some of the uh
about some of the ticket choices that
that people have made
um so far so we have so 62 percent of
our
um current audience think that jocko and
tulsi are both charismatic
that would be able to win over a lot of
voters from either of their respective
sides of the aisle
and a lot of the answers that we're
getting here are all based on the
character
of the candidates which is something
that you don't hear a lot of people talk
about anymore you don't hear people talk
about character as much as you hear them
talk about
you know the negative aspects of people
and and
and what's not and what's not serving
you in particular but here
our second answer we have that um andrew
and jocko have qualities which appeal to
both sides and less dirty laundry
which i think really speaks to the
values driven aspect of
unity 2020 um
in in a way that i think that you know
none of the political parties
do at the moment yeah i think that's
uh well said now one thing that i
thought
was interesting was our process you know
we're all
new to this everybody including me in
this
entity is a volunteer and we're
discovering how to do this
on the fly nonetheless we've created a
process we've attracted
people these people have expressed
preferences
it is amazing how um
[Music]
nonpartisan things are within
the movement and how balanced the
nomination process ended up being
between right and left that was an
accident that the
the top six who were the most popular
by a a large margin turned out to be so
evenly
uh divided as they did but i think
the thing that's hard for me to express
is
how easy in some sense that means it is
to find candidates that are better than
the ones settled on
by the parties that there's something
about the process that the parties
engage in and i would argue
about the thing that drives the parties
the actual
purpose that those parties serve its
purpose is not to find
high quality patriotic leaders if it was
it would succeed much better than it
actually does
it's doing something else and it's
pretending to identify these people
and so if nothing else i think we have
established
that citizens simply figuring out
how to arrange a process that works
better
aren't finding that difficult we are
able to identify
people who are more qualified less
polarizing
people who can talk to each other i mean
one of the
it's a shame that chelsea was not able
to join uh
dan and me and uh eric would also have
been present in that conversation but
one of the things that's so interesting
is dan and tulsi are from opposite sides
of the
aisle but they're friends they get along
they don't have a problem interacting
productively so
this tells us how far off our process is
that it's constantly settling on
people um who are uh less capable of
interaction and
uh less likely to trigger people's
um sense that they are honorable
yeah i couldn't agree what more with you
brett and i think that
this movement for me has really been a
proof of concept um
you know my friends and family asked me
what i've been doing for the last month
and a half and
um i have found a group of people
that believe that we can come together
in disagreement and fully make
things better and make the country
better and i think that
the candidates that we've chosen and
that we've nominated
are are like the biggest um the biggest
manifestation of that because every day
we're all
you know back and forth and we spent so
many hours making this happen
and this has been truly a show that
america is still capable of agreement
and coming together
and compromising on things that need to
be compromised in order to make progress
and it's really been a beautiful process
yeah it is
um i i hope we succeed but you know
succeed or fail at the uh initial
mission that we've
chosen it is heartening to have
a process that brings together people
who are clearly
ready to to participate this way with
each other and so
it's also something i've seen in my life
prior to unity 2020
where um i found myself interacting with
lots of people who were
you know quote unquote from the other
side lots of conservatives
and it was amazing how regularly i
felt uh welcomed by them i got a lot of
curiosity
you know there was a belief among many
conservatives
that uh you know a rational liberal was
not something that they
uh were even sure existed and
in any case i've had many many
conversations and uh
it's we are told things that are not
true
about how difficult it is for us to get
along and
um hopefully the unity movement will
reveal to people that there is a path to
getting along and it's not that
difficult it really
it's a matter of uh disbelieving what
you've been told about how
unreasonable other people inherently are
yeah there was a there was a moment
during the uh 2016 primaries that
stuck with me like a knife in the back
uh
and it was during one of the primary
debates
and it was sort of the last closing
question
and for the democratic primary and
the question asked was to the effect of
what do you think is the greatest
threat to america
and i don't know whether it was just
bernie
and hillary at this point or whether
there were some other answers but i only
remember there are two answers
bernie said climate change and yeah you
know that's a standard
uh left-leaning answer um you know you
wouldn't
necessarily get a lot of agreement to
that on the right side of the aisle
but hillary's answer was the republicans
and in that moment in that moment
she lost the election and won the
primary
and that's the problem with our process
right now right is because we have these
engines that force you
to tear apart the country
in order to have the chance of running
it
and it needs change and to to riff off
your point elizabeth
i just have to echo everything you said
you know since
joining this incredible group of
volunteers
i am gobsmacked day after day
after day of just how much work
people are putting in and how much just
raw talent and creativity is at display
every single day
and the best part is i think
maybe there's i've met dozens of people
over the last you know several weeks and
months um that i've worked with on
various projects
and i think i maybe know
two of their political orientations like
it doesn't come up
we recognize the promise like okay if we
can if we can get off this brink
if we can save ourselves from this
hazard
then let's start an argument and let's
have some great arguments but first
let's let's solve let's bail the water
out of the boat
um and get to shore in time and it's
just
it's incredibly encouraging because
right to your point you know we're
everyone knows
we're making a moon shot right now like
no no one has any illusions about it you
know we're not delusional people
we're recognizing the magnitude of the
challenge
and recognizing that given the magnitude
of
of the danger we have to attempt the
magnitude of the challenge
and if we fail then this is the network
of people
that i want to be able to call to
lower the temperature and
keep keep our country together in the
wake
of the of whatever happens on november
4th
when you know when trump cries fraud
or biden cries suppression and every
and some number of people regardless of
whether they're from the blue team or
the red team
are in the streets ready for blood
so i want to talk about
two things that uh surround
this issue one of them has to do with
what we think is in the minds
of people who
we would imagine would be on board and
yet
are uh slow to come around
so i'm i can't quite help it but i'm
building a model in my own mind
of what people's resistance is because
you know
in their regular lives i hear people uh
complaining about the quality of the
choices they've been offered
i hear people fearing for the future
i see people choosing to move
like leaving cities that they've lived
in for decades
some of them are selling homes they
don't even know where they're going
right so there's something going on that
would
seem to suggest that this was obviously
the moment i mean we haven't
elected the next president it seems like
an obvious moment
at which we could do something new and
different and yet
even as people are upending their lives
and
contemplating things they never thought
that they would have to
to worry about there is still resistance
to something
of this nature and so anyway i'd be
curious if you guys have a sense
of what it is that keeps people from
joining and
then i'd be happy to share what i think
is up
well really quick i think this is a
perfect question
uh noah if you're on the line listening
um if we can relay this question to uh
to those watching because i'd love to
hear um what the democracy ai has to say
about it
and let me just interrupt you at the
ryan because democracy ai
65 of our of our participants want to
know what we see as the biggest
challenges for this movement
and i think that's really the biggest
question on everyone yeah so we're all
you know
we're all of like mine okay cool right
it's all
fine in the room right
and the donkey and the dog
so to if i can rephrase your question a
little bit
um i think what is it
that stops someone who buys a bumper
sticker that says giant meteor 2020 or
any functioning adult 2020 what is it
that
stops the person that buys that bumper
sticker
from signing on board because it seems
like that
that that's the bumper sticker version
that
that illustrates the problem but for
some reason
there's instead of actually trying to
articulate or
fight for or seek a solution
it turns into cynicism so
is it is it just the sheer sense of
impossibility is it just the sheer sense
of being outnumbered
or the learned helplessness helplessness
uh as
eric said on the first campfire you know
what is it well i think
go ahead i was gonna say that i think a
lot of it comes down to comfort
people are comfortable where they are as
far as where they are intellectually or
where they are
in their day-to-day lives whether or not
that means that they struggle
financially or anything like that i
think it's really difficult for people
to make a change and for people to
imagine something that's not there
it's deeply unsettling and uncomfortable
to imagine something that
doesn't exist and then when the answer
to your questions
or when the answer to you know whatever
you can't imagine when it's right in
front of you it's even more difficult to
accept that i think because
you have a different idea what it should
look like or this or that you just have
these different conceptions and so
i think i think our biggest challenge is
showing people that we're all in this
together and we're all learning together
and nobody has all the answers and
that's something that
i think is really important to remember
is that
while we're up here and you know we we
hit
we we've been in this movement for a
while and brett has
you know a lot of public notoriety none
of us
have all of the answers um but we can
but we can find the solution together
and i think that's what's really
important to remember but it's difficult
for people to get there because we want
to be told what to do and when to do it
well i want to point out something i
think you're right about
comfort and i think you're right about
um
your answer hints at the following thing
people fear being blamed
for something right everybody knows that
there's an
outcome in the next election that will
cause whatever group they're hanging out
with
to be frightened and upset
and it doesn't matter whether you
understand for example that we built
the unity 2020 proposal
uh so that it would not spoil an
election
so that we would not be putting people
who support us in the position of being
blamed
people are so used to the idea that if
you do
anything other than what your friend
group is saying is the required action
in this election
that you're responsible for whatever
outcome might happen other
than you know the win and i should say
for whatever reason
i'm hearing this more from uh
democrats at the moment than i am from
republicans and i don't know why that is
because i don't think it's inherently
one side of the aisle or the other but
in this election there is a sense
of moral obligation not to think outside
the box and people
say this they say you know blue no
matter who
right blue no matter who and they'll you
know they'll frankly
talk about all sorts of things that
might be true of biden
that don't dissuade them from thinking
that this is the answer and
i think what distinguishes the
constituency of the unity movement
is a recognition
that it actually everybody seems to see
one disaster or the other and a small
number of people
see two disasters and an uncertain
choice between them i honestly don't
know which outcome i
fear more right i know that
trump nominally is farther from the
values that i think are most important
but i don't know that a trump presidency
is more dangerous than a biden
presidency in light of what biden
is playing with in terms of
partners and policy so yeah
to me you know i'm not all that
interested in
which disaster it's going to be because
i think both of these disasters are so
dangerous
that it is unthinkable that we cannot at
least attempt to divert our course
which is the whole reason i'm here it's
i'm trying to divert our course from
disaster
and i think a lot of people who were
thinking similarly
heard that message and responded but
when we talk to other people if you if
you have a blind spot that covers one of
the disasters
right and you only see the other
disaster then the point is well this
election is as obvious as it could be
right you got to vote for a or you've
got to vote for b
and the problem is um how do you reveal
to people what's in
their blind spot yeah
i think there's there's something i want
to highlight
about what you just said and having you
know watched
a lot of your arguments and streams for
a while now brett i
i find that there's
there's a response that comes back to
not necessarily your arguments in
specific but
this style of argument that's tries to
not have
either of those blind spots that tries
to recognize
where we're at and it's the it's the
both side isms it's the milk toast mod
this is discussed with milk toast
moderated
uh moderation um and
the thing to convey and i i'm saying
this just because i think it's important
for people to know
is that it's not the argument isn't that
the two sides are the same they're very
different they have a very different
taste and character
and shape um and
but you know there's they have a charge
symmetry right the tension between the
two of them
is in some sort of balance even though
it's playing out in different fields
right
in the on the federal government in the
federal government right now
the republican interests are
overwhelmingly overrepresented in the
in the sort of if if i could coin the
the sort of
federal cultural government right in
hollywood and in the universities it's
universally left of the center right so
there's
there's domain distinctions about where
these
battles are playing out but they're
still
that there's a symmetry of tension and
i'm less interested
in which team wins the tug of war
what i'm interested in is the amount of
explosive potential energy that is being
generated in the rope
because when that rope snaps like it
doesn't matter
who gave the the last tug that snapped
the rope
what matters is that the rope is
snapping and we're all going to be
bleeding
yeah i think that's very very well said
um nonetheless i i have
a sense that people there's something in
the tension between
people's if people fast forward and
anything
that is just pleasing to their
social group occurs in this election
they fear that they will be blamed if
they have
done anything other than the standard
thing and i think frankly
it i almost see like rooms full of
people
all of them wanting to entertain some
other possibility
but all of them are afraid that the room
is going to hold them
responsible and um you know
it's the kind of thing that really it
requires almost
a comedian to figure out how to phrase
it to get everybody to laugh
and simultaneously acknowledge they're
all fearing each other
you know they're everybody's fearing the
room is going to hold them responsible
when really the room wants to revolt
together
yeah and let me just uh chime in here
with the audience's answers which are
much much simpler than ours
so effectively our audience says that
people haven't heard about it
um that they don't know about it or
that it's impossible and i think we've
sort of touched on the impossible part
and that's sort of like
stepping outside of your frame of mind
so that you can see that maybe this is
i mean this is viable first of all it's
20 20 and anything is possible
second of all it's possible um because
we do have a plan
and one of the other um big questions
from the last poll of when we asked you
um when we asked the audience four
questions was
let me pull it up right here sorry i'm
pulling it up um
[Music]
here we go are you keeping the ballot
access strategy a secret because those
who oppose unity 2020 could foil the
plan
in some way if it worked to get out and
i think that this question
hits on a lot of aspects of what we're
all saying what's holding people
back yes people don't know about it but
when they do
they recognize that their forces that
are working against us
and that could work against us that
could that could seriously damage the
movement
um and that's not a reason that
uh you know that
well i've lost my train of thought now
but that's the question
is are you keeping the ballot access
strategy a secret because those who
oppose unity2020 could foil the plan in
some way if it were to get out
i'll let you take that one yeah um so
let's just say first of all
we all know the plan there is one okay
so the people who say there's no plan
that this is mathematically impossible
at this point are just
simply incorrect
the only reason to keep it secret is to
keep
the those who oppose any sort of unity
plan
including unity 2020
from foiling the plan in order to
continue to
hold whatever power they hold so um i
don't think that it's a secret that
a plan that seeks to restore
the public's influence over policy would
have many
enemies that those enemies would be well
resourced and would
use any means at their disposal so
there's really no reason to share
information with them
so it just seems to me very
straightforward
we could in an effort to show that we
are
you know not lying we could reveal the
plan at
some substantial cost to the plans
working now that said we are getting to
a point
where uh it becomes important
to share the plan and to activate it and
uh we will get there soon if you want to
be kept apprised of things this is a an
excellent reason that you should
register
uh for our email list so that you can um
be looped in as quickly as possible but
i think
at some level i want those
who are listening to listen
better and to think harder right
to the extent that you want something
different to happen to the extent that
you are looking at the
choices that the major parties have
delivered you and thinking to yourself
oh my god how could we possibly be in
such a bind
then you are also somebody who should be
open to the idea
that if there's a way to get there and
it requires you not knowing this instant
exactly how it works
that you should be on board with that
and you know if it turns out we're lying
i guess you'll find that out and we'll
have egg on our face but would we really
be doing that
it just doesn't make any sense from i
mean you know from my perspective does
it make sense to pretend that there's a
plan when there isn't when that will
ultimately become clear
of course it doesn't so um it doesn't
mean the plan will work
doesn't mean you're going to like it but
is there a plan of course and
uh we've been clear with you all along
about that
yeah i'd like to add on to that
oh you go elizabeth no please ryan
well there's a distinction right and
this
this is clear to all of us and it's
clear to everyone that's already signed
on
but i think it's sometimes not clear to
the critics or at least they weaponize
the potential
ambiguity that a a plan is not
synonymous with a guarantee
right um so if i can touch on that that
word impossible
right um there's two types of impossible
there's very very very very difficult
and then there's perpetual motion
there's violating the second law of
thermodynamics
right um and a plan
gets you to the second type of
impossible but
you know it was impossible for colonists
to go up against the largest empire of
the world that's ever known
it was impossible to abolish slavery and
maintain the union it was impossible to
fly it was impossible to secure
women's suffrage it was impossible to go
to the moon
the history of this country is a history
of
impossible accomplishments and it's our
turn so are you going to try or are you
going to
give up without trying and let our
country disintegrate
which it clearly is doing so you know
we're being forced into uh
into attempting the impossible and it
shouldn't shock anybody that
people are responding anyway go ahead
elizabeth
oh no i was going to say that um so
and when you when our audience on
democracy ai went through the onboarding
questions they identified as
um their their different age groups so
we categorize people into boomers
millennials etc
and it seems that boomers and
millennials surprise surprise don't
agree
on a lot of things however um we see
that
you know there is a lot of entrenchment
from boomers
on not being able to break outside of
the frames that they don't think it's
realistic
and they can't get away from the party
um that cynicism is too high
and so i think we need to really
ryan to your point like look to these
things in the past that we've
accomplished and all of these
you know incredible things that were
never possible that now
you know shape our world um we need to
really look
look forward take those and look forward
into the future
and not um and not rely on the frames
that
that were once that that have once
served us
yeah i mean we are in some sense or
didn't even serve us
really i mean if you look at it they
didn't really serve us at all because
look at where we are
however we can accomplish so much and we
need to believe in ourselves to do that
we need to believe in this so at some
level i would
ask people um to
stop considering unity 2020 in
isolation right you may consider this so
unlikely as to be not worth considering
but how likely is it that a major party
would field a candidate who can't be
allowed off
script because he's no longer competent
to uh deploy a message
off the cuff this is a remarkable thing
this is a candidate who's going to face
debates presumably
nobody knows how that's going to play
out so we are dealing with a landscape
that is
already um in the realm of the
impossible
not because of anything that we've done
we're just simply responding to it so
anyway it's a landscape of the
impossible it is the era of the
impossible
and the fact that this is an impossible
uh plan
as ryan points out it's it's of uh was
it type two impossibility ryan
did i it was yeah type two impossibility
all right do we have more um data coming
back from democracy ai
indeed we do um we have a question here
uh what's the plan for continuing the
movement after november if not enough
swell to activate in this election
and what i would say to that is that
unity 2020
unity is about leadership and regardless
of our moonshot what unity does is it
shows us who our leaders are in this
country and it helps us identify leaders
not only on the public sphere but
in our own channels and in ourselves and
so
i think that no matter what happens we
need to continue seeking the values in
other people
and finding the leaders that we deserve
yeah i think this is this is exactly
right and one thing
i in fact in all of the conversations
inside the unity movement
that i've been party to this has never
really been a question
wasn't on my mind when i set the ball in
motion but as soon as people started to
gather around it and it became clear
that we don't see exactly the same thing
but we see
very much um analogous
frightening processes unfolding danger
to the republic
that seems to call many of us to action
if the plan fails to
recapture the white house in 2020
that's a terrible setback but it doesn't
reduce the need for a unity movement
obviously the need for a unity movement
only increases in that frightening
circumstance so at some level it has to
continue
uh we are learning from this process
we're discovering each other which is
really
um it's a great reason to join is that
finding out how many people you know
far-flung people that you would never
have encountered otherwise
uh are feeling the same way about where
we are and recognizing the same sorts of
obligation that yeah the movement has to
continue
it has to do whatever is necessary and i
would say in some sense
what i'm realizing is that it is
simultaneously a movement
that is apolitical it is non-ideological
but that that has more content than you
would imagine
in other words a non-ideological
movement
should oppose corruption and so in some
sense unity is inherently
a movement against corruption it is a
movement about
restoring the democratic force so that
it governs policy
you know essentially if your ideology is
non-ideological if you believe in
democracy if you believe that consent of
the governed
is the source of the legitimacy of
government
then you should be for a process that
purifies that so that
it actually is meaningful consent of the
governed rather than
coerced consent where really you know
manufactured consent as chomsky would
have it
um so yes the movement has to continue
i'm sure it will
change in the aftermath of this election
one way or the other
hopefully we can keep it on this
positive track because
inside the movement it is uh hopeful
and reassuring and patriotic and as ryan
said up at the top
you meet people you find that you are
very much in alignment with them
and you don't know their political
background because
it's not highly relevant right
patriotism is patriotism
and to your to your point brett um i
think
as much as this is about leadership it's
about teamwork
and that's the whole point of the unity
ticket and in thinking about the
candidates i know that
let's say crenshaw for instance a lot of
people think that maybe crenshaw
is um you know not favorable enough to
the
to the democrats or or something like
that
and what i say to that is that okay so
if crenshaw's then paired with tulsi
gabbard
that balance is out and so you know that
someone's fighting for you in the office
and someone
and it's it's it's really about balance
and about and about
i mean unity but leadership and teamwork
um effectively yeah and leadership
not just in the political realm right
it's you know i've i've met more leaders
in the last three weeks than in probably
in my
entire life uh interacting with this
team
and you know the the people
that get on board that i've seen
you know those are the people that when
there's tear gas in a street and there's
a standoff
between some group of nut cases and i
don't care what banner they're flying
but some group of nut cases
and some group of authoritarians when
there's standoff and there's tear gas
and there's rubber bullets
you know these are the people
that are going to run out and pull a kid
out of
a fog of tear gas and give them a bottle
of water and give them shelter those the
people that are going to
look out for their fellow citizens
no matter what and that that's the
banner
that we're flying under right now and
that's going to be our job if we don't
get in the oval office if we're not able
to
prevent this whatever sort of
snap or schizophrenic fit that our
country is headed towards
um our job is to heal
and protect each other uh in
whatever challenges we have to go
through afterwards
all right i want to try a formulation
out on you
when when the evergreen
situation happened to heather and me
we were asked to reflect on it many many
times by many different people and it
became clear
that there were a few things that were
the key lessons
the one that maybe is most prominent in
my thinking
is crisis reveals everyone's character
for both better and worse i've seen
people
who you would absolutely think would be
courageous fold
and display pure cowardice and i've seen
people that you wouldn't imagine
had uh heroic courage within them
display it and the sense is there was
nobody left
on the sidelines afterward because the
crisis forced everybody to reveal which
of those things
resided within them and i think
if we can go back a little bit to the
conversation we were having 20 minutes
ago
i think there's a difference between
seeing
a crisis and thinking it's other people
and seeing a national crisis that
clearly
involves us all only one of those things
produces
the reaction to crisis that will tell us
who you really are right until you see
that
actually it's crisis either way we don't
know
because people are telling themselves oh
it's very simple you just do this you
you know pull the lever for these people
so i guess what i'm
i'm thinking is in some sense
the unity movement is composed of people
who have seen the full crisis early
enough
and reacted with courage rather than
cowardice
and what i'm hoping is that however it
happens
as the crisis reveals itself as it
becomes impossible to deny
that there is no safe answer here that
both answers are dangerous in different
ways
and we're going to get um a very
destructive outcome
in either case as that reveals itself
people's character will also and
i think the point is it's not really
unity
or not it's unity now or
when you finally get around to
recognizing how much danger we're in
for for the courageous people i think
that's kind of it at some point
you're going to break free from the
narrative you've been told is right
which is
you have to choose this side because the
other side is is
is the hazard
and i would imagine that a lot of our
viewers right now and especially people
on democracy ai
are these courageous patriots who want
to know what they can do and how we're
going to do it and a lot of the
questions that we're getting on
democracy ai
are about strategy and numbers and where
we are right now
and um i think that it's really
important to reiterate
i know we keep saying it like broken
records but the ground swell
is hugely important to our success
and so strategies around that we are
cooking them they are on the way and
also it begins with you
and it begins with and it begins with
the people that you can tell the people
that you can convince that something is
really wrong and that we have the
solution
um and something else brett that uh
a lot of people are asking is have we
spoken to the candidates
who are who have been nominated and i
think that's a fair question because we
need to know
you know how how viable are these
candidates and in the beginning of the
show we talked about the political
complexity of
coming out in favor of unity or not and
if you know if if anyone did that now it
would almost be like
political suicide so um if we could
speak a little bit about that and about
our candidates and how how we're
communicating with them and if we are
that would be
i think the audience would like to know
sure um
so let me say we have not sought the
candidates out it's too early we need a
groundswell
that's really on the public um i can't
say who we have and have not spoken to
but i can say there has not been
a systematic effort to talk to people
who have been nominated because at the
moment
what this is is um we are building
to a draft and
i believe everyone on the list that
was advanced the list of six would take
the job if we could provide a path to it
um and they would do so on the basis
that they clearly
are patriotic they love their country
they understand the importance
of this nation to the functioning of the
west
and that means that whether it's a job
they want
or not that it's the right thing to do
but
uh you know put yourself in their shoes
this is
the movement is not big enough to
to ask somebody to compromise themselves
politically
in any other milieu nor would we want
them to because
if unity 2020 fails to win the white
house
this time around these people are still
prominent functionaries within
the the structure and so to the extent
that the right things are
desirable if the structure continues to
limp along the way it is
then we want these people as powerful as
they can be within the movement which
does not does not mean uh that it makes
sense for us to approach them this early
that said we would like to have the
firepower
that it would make sense to approach
them and say there's a path
we have the power to make this happen
and will you join us so
we're looking for that moment and we
hope we get there
and i think sorry ryan i keep
interrupting but i think i think what
um something to to tack on to that is
that
we need so we know that all of our
candidates right now they all have
huge support already on twitter and
social media they already have a huge
following
we need you they're following who are
sure are tuning into this to see you
know can my candidate
get past the rnc and dnc that they
haven't been able to bypass in
years um is it viable and can they do it
and we need your help and your support
in getting out to your
you know the leaders that you want in
this country to really
uh to really make this work so again and
i know i keep saying it
but this starts with you and the
groundswell really is about you
communicating
with your people it is yeah and go ahead
oh well i first of all elizabeth
uh don't apologize for interrupting me i
was praying that you would say something
because i was uh i was deep in thought
so second of all
yeah i think you know
we're going to be building out as
as much tooling as we can for you
the our the supporters our fellow
patriots
to convince your friends family
and build this groundswell
but if you feel disheartened uh consider
consider the the elephant in the room of
2020 right everyone understands that
what an r-value is right now because
we've had this pandemic and we know
how we we now know why you call it going
viral
when something gets really possible on
social media because we finally
we're being presented with this real
world example from whence the
the term came um so
we it's short notice but it can be done
we can have a pandemic of patriotism in
this country
um and that's what we have to do that's
a terrible
terrible metaphor
surely surely we have somebody expert in
marketing who can talk you out of
yourself
yeah you are a tech guy yeah well i just
said it out loud
[Laughter]
yes um yeah pandemic is definitely not
in 2020 especially it's not the term you
want to use but anyway i i
interrupted you if you if we if we
imagine no no no
i was clearly saying something stupid so
you should have no you were saying
something smart
in an unpalatable way um
all right so um here's the thing
there is organic skepticism
and there is cultivated skepticism of
what we're up to
the parties have invested mightily in
the idea that nothing outside of them
can work and this is clearly
incorrect but people have accepted it
and they have
understood that to play with things
outside of the mainstream offerings
is to invite ridicule and stigma
and you know many will remember
that hillary clinton portrayed tulsi
gabbard
as a russian asset right
during the primaries it was a very nasty
stigma for her to deploy
obviously one that had no basis in
reality but the idea was
to tar her with the same brush that had
been used
for jill stein the idea being that
anything outside
of the um the mainstream offerings
empowers the greater evil now of course
we've
dealt with this ad nauseam this plan is
built so it doesn't
create that hazard to the extent that it
is for some reason in this election
cycle
democrats who are complaining loudly
about the possibility of spoiling the
election
actually unity 2020 seems to draw
slightly greater support
from republicans and so therefore
uh if spoiling is your fear
it should be the republicans who level
that accusation to the extent that
there's any bias whatsoever it is in
that direction
and yet we don't typically hear it from
them we hear it from
uh from democrats but what i want to get
at
is somehow we have to
reject the idea that we will take
responsibility
for the whatever bad outcome it is that
people fear in this election
uh for daring to think outside the box
the fact is the bad outcomes
are the responsibility of the parties
right this is the natural outgrowth of
the corrupt system
that they have instantiated and all of
the bulwark that they have installed to
make sure that nothing can challenge it
our challenging it is absolutely
necessary at this point
we are if anything late to the party not
early
to the extent that people are saying oh
do this in 2024.
my feeling is this should have been 2016
right
this is a disaster already well underway
and so if you're contemplating
uh joining unity 2020 or becoming public
about your skepticism about the major
party offerings
then what we can say is
there's a very vibrant group of people
who have already
forged this path and are um
not going to accept blame in fact i
think the point is
we are trying to avert the disaster that
is coming
and the disaster belongs squarely at the
feet of people who did nothing
so it is quite the opposite of the
stigmatizing story that has been
advertised to you
and i think we should just make no bones
about that
jump on in the water's fine
the water's fine it's going to boil but
it's not there yet
and when we asked our audience about
what they can do to increase
um to increase our support uh the top
answer
was to have conversations about uw 2020
with friends and family
this person has plenty of friends from
all over the spectrum
and that's really important to recognize
is that you do have friends and family
from all different political walks of
life and what do you love to be able to
have thanksgiving dinner and not
really be super stressed about that
conversation
that that's gonna happen um not too
sorry not to trigger anyone
but another thing that people um
that that people are saying is is
posting on social media and this is
something that we haven't quite touched
on yet
is is the power of social media and how
it can be
a powerful tool and also hugely
detrimental i think that
echo chambers are keeping us all from
each other you know they're the caves
that we find ourselves in
it's really stepping outside of those
and sharing messages that maybe people
in your newsfeed have never seen
people in your timeline have never seen
um i think is really important and so
we do have tons of content that we would
love for you to share we're sharing with
you all the time on twitter and
instagram
any of our official channels articles of
unity
and then we have a lot of other um you
know awesome awesome fan pages
and so uh you can check those out on our
website and
this is how we get you know this is how
we get the word out and this is how we
increase our support
and we and we're glad that you recognize
that these are the modes that we're
doing it in
yeah i if i could riff on that just a
tiny bit
um social media is great
but it's also part of the engine that
got us to where we are
right those echo chambers um to your
point elizabeth
what i would suggest is get to know your
neighbors again
get to know the people that are within
200 feet of you
90 99 of your day that
you might not even know their names
because of
the sort of direction that the country
has been going with depersonalization
and sort of
commodification of of uh of every
interaction
um those one-on-one conversations like
it's really hard number one to get out
of the echo chamber and number two
that the thing that you brett we're
talking about that
whatever that social force is that says
oh if i'm going to think outside the box
the room is going to punish me right
a one-on-one conversation isn't
is way safer than you think it is
because if you go into a one-on-one
conversation with a thought
with psychologically that you're under
the gun of the group
the same person who might join in the
taunting and mocking and saying that's
impossible or that's harmful don't you
dare do that
in the group context approaching them as
an individual
you can actually get them to leave
the script right because the script is
provided
by the group of 30 and they they invent
it on the fly or
it emerges as some sort of multi-person
uh emergent script right but a
one-on-one conversation
it's actually remarkably easy to have
those if you remember how
and they're both even aside from unity
2020
they're great for your psychological
well-being to actually have those
one-on-one interactions with people and
they are the most genuine
and most effective way to
connect with people and convince them
and even be convinced
and that's the the high ideal of
negotiation that we're
looking for in our eventual ticket and
also looking for in our nation's culture
so start to embody that right away and
see what happens
and uh i want to add two things because
i do think you're right
there's all the difference in the world
between trying to do this in person
or at least personally with somebody
rather than
where everything you're saying is
broadcast and it produces the expected
reaction
one thing is that you will be shocked at
how frequently
somebody is harboring similar thoughts
but isn't saying so because of what they
fear
so i live in portland as you many of you
will know
and when i interact with people i am
very careful
not to nod along to
the conventional wisdom of the left
which is obviously very prevalent here
in portland
but here's the interesting thing
this has never gone bad
never once where if
somebody voices an opinion
it's very frequent that i have a
different opinion that
contradicts the conventional wisdom and
i'm very careful to see if i can say it
in such a way that it can be heard
and it is amazing how frequently
what happens is somebody will say one of
the standard things that you say
nowadays
and i will say you know i don't see it
that way here's how i see it
and then what comes back is oh me too i
also have a suspicion that it isn't
quite right it's that or the other way
literally this has never once gone badly
and so what i would say is
there's a skill it's very often that
both of the
standard viewpoints are just wrong and
there's some viewpoint that's
approximately right
it's not necessarily in the middle but
it's composed of different stuff
right so you know for example you will
hear
from some people very often on the right
that
uh covet 19 is much less serious
than we thought that it's you know it's
a flu at worst
right and you will hear people on
the left typically talking about
uh the numbers of people who are dying
from it and the you know the massive
death toll already and so what i
frequently say to people is you know
it's much less deadly
than we feared and much more destructive
right you can't hear that as one or the
other because it isn't
either of them the idea that fewer
people are dying but more of the people
who are recovering
are actually permanently damaged that
that is something you have to engage
consciously and actively because it's
not of some known
stripe so my point is on virtually
every issue there's some way of not
being seen by the person you're talking
to
as simply part of that group that they
dislike and distrust
and if you can figure out how to say
things such that you don't get
immediately categorized as oh another
one of those
you know maga hat wearing or another one
of those black lives matter this that or
the other
if you can just stay out of those traps
then you can have the conversation that
ryan is suggesting
that you have and you'll be amazed at um
a how wonderful it is to discover that
those conversations can be had
even with strangers and b how much more
progress you're likely to make in
convincing people that there's something
to be done
all right i agree and let me just let me
just point in one more thing from
um from the audience so first this is so
democracy ai is a really
cool tool and um we have an awesome team
on the back end shout out to chris and
noah
who are you know synthesizing this
as we're going and they pointed out that
first-time democracy ai users are a
little less likely than the average
respondent
to talk to others about unity 2020 and i
think that's really important to
to note because i would well i would
think that first time users are maybe
tuning into this for for the first time
or they just aren't as engaged um you
know maybe like directly because we do
have a lot of other answers that you
know we have a lot of
current volunteers on this call um so
what i would say is that
you have a home here like this like if
you if you need talking points if you
need to just understand that there are
people out there who
agree with you about the fact that
disagreement is okay
we're here and um
we have a really exciting thing to
announce uh at the end of the show
where you can connect with other people
so stick around i know we're running a
little bit over but um
we'll get to it in just a minute i just
want to say that 70 of our audience
agree that talking to friends family and
co-workers about unity 2020 is the way
that we're going to get this going
and we just have one more question for
you um
no if you want to fire that off then
people can answer
and the question is after this
conversation
did your ticket preference change and
we might not have talked directly about
the candidates but maybe maybe you
started to see things in a different
light or maybe
you know in engaging maybe you're on
twitter maybe you're on instagram and
you're seeing what the other candidates
or sorry what other people are saying
maybe maybe your preference has changed
and so we just like to see
you know if this conversation hadn't had
any impact on that
great okay um so
seems to me that we are drawing to the
end of the conversation
um are we going to await answers
on that question well i can give my
answer to that okay
um because it actually has changed i
have gone from
uh really preferring a center left
paired with a center right
to preferring a center right paired with
a center left
candidate which i think is is quite an
important distinction
depending on the results of the coin
flip
um you want to spell that out a little
bit more ryan
uh no that was uh that was an attempt at
uh dry british humor
right no american
no you did i just didn't want to laugh
and then discover that you had actually
meant something deep and
leave you insulted and wounded here on
camera with
oh well like i can take the laughter
that's fine fair enough
all right so are we going to await uh
the
audience's answer to that question
um we don't i just saw one really
interesting answer that said i don't
have a preference
yet but i really really really don't
want to vote for so i really really
really want to vote for a ticket that's
not devoured by corruption
and i think that's a pretty salient uh
response
wonderful keeping keeping an open mind
and understanding that you know
where where we're at well i think this
is another it's another thing that
uh unity has really accomplished already
is that
um you know the fact of the obvious
corruption of these parties
has been difficult to talk about right
there's a tendency to want to see them
as
somewhat corrupt and i think they have
revealed themselves as much more corrupt
than that
and to the extent that we can now talk
about that
in the open that is progress of an
important kind because really the
question is until that problem is solved
we face the same issue and we will
continue to face it
every election so uh hence
unity all right so
i think we should close this out here um
before we do that we should alert you
that there
is um a
i don't exactly know how to describe it
there is something unfolding in the
aftermath of this campfire
that involves let me take it okay yeah
go for it elizabeth let me take it brett
so um a lot of a lot of our volunteers
all of our supporters
have been wanting to connect with people
after the show and in general throughout
the week and just in daily life
and so what we've created right now is
something called a campfire s'mores
and so these more sessions are for our
viewers to
connect after the show to talk about the
campfire to talk about
unity to talk about sort of what's going
on in the world right now and so we hope
that you participate we hope that you
join
and you're going to go to well to the
url campfiresmores.articles
and again you're able to connect you're
able to share and you're able to really
grow with people
who are like-minded but also just
and also disagree not but and and also
disagree and i think that
uh well we hope that it'll be a really
great experience for everyone so
head over again to
campfiresmores.articlesofunity.org and
zach's going to throw a slide up at the
end
that uh that will tell you that url so
these uh these s'mores are they um
gluten-free of course
i'm also gluten-free so they have to
they have to be gluten-free
good are they vegetarian i
am sure these s'mores have never eaten
meat that is my feeling about them
all right i dodged that bullet did i not
okay
good great uh any final thoughts ryan or
elizabeth
uh thank you everyone watching and thank
you brett for having us
yeah thank you thank you guys it's been
a fun conversation and i also want to
thank uh you both individually and as
representatives of our amazing
team of volunteers i want to thank you
for everything that you're
investing in this i know it is taking a
huge amount
from you and i um i'm thrilled to meet
kindred spirits who are similarly
motivated to do something because
god damn right okay uh
anyway thank you all for joining us and
we will see you on the next campfire
don't forget to register for our email
list
and uh if you're there to vote uh for
which
tickets you want to see give us your
ranked choice
on that um all right see you all soon
[Music]
enough
[Music]
you
[Music]
me
[Music]
you